I'M GUILTY.
- OH, DEAR GOD.
- GUILTY OF FALLING
FOR ONE OF THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL WOMEN IN THE WORLD.
- [laughing]
OH, ARMOND.
- I DIDN'T MURDER HER, KELSEY.
I NEED YOU TO BELIEVE ME.
BUT JUST IN CASE,
MAYBE GET A WHITE BRONCO.
[doorbell rings]
- ARMOND, THE COPS ARE HERE.
AM I GONNA MISS SHANNON?
HELL NO.
THAT BITCH WAS WACK.
YOU KNOW, REST IN PEACE.
MAKE ME A FEAST, HO.
[device beeps]
- DR. ARMOND,
THIS IS OFFICER LONG.
I'M DETECTIVE SMART.
- YOU MUST BE TO RISE
TO THE RANK OF DETECTIVE.
- THIS IS MY BEAUTIFUL SON
ROMAN.
[smack]
- WELL, YOU MUST VERY PROUD.
- FIRST, I HAD TO CONVINCE
THIS DETECTIVE
THAT I HADN'T MURDERED
MY WIFE.
BUT ALMOST MORE IMPORTANTLY,
I HAD TO MAKE SURE THAT MY SON
HAD THE BREAKFAST HE SO DESIRED.
- WHERE WERE YOU WHEN YOU FIRST
DISCOVERED YOUR WIFE'S BODY?
- I WAS DECIDING
WHETHER TO SEVER HER...
- [screams]
- TIES TO ME.
[squeak]
- DO YOU HAVE ANY ACCESS
TO SEDATIVES OR DRUGS?
- ONLY ENOUGH TO KILL A HORSE.
[whip cracks,
horse neighs]
- YOU'RE NOT INTIMIDATING ME
WITH YOUR FANCY SHIRT.
I KNOW WHAT YOU DID.
- IS IT OKAY IF I GO?
- I JUST PREPARED
A FEAST FOR YOU.
- I'M NOT EATING THAT.
I'M GOING TO CHICK CLUB
WITH MY FRIENDS.
THIS LOOKS LIKE [bleep].
- BUT THE JOKE'S ON HIM.
MORE FOR ME.
- WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU?
LIKE, YOUR FACE
ISN'T EVEN MOVING.
YOUR WIFE JUST DIED.
- WHAT WOULD BE
A MORE APPROPRIATE THING
FOR ME TO DO WITH MY FACE?
- HAVE IT MOVE.
- [howling]
SINCE MY TEAR DUCTS
ARE NOW CLOSED,
THE ONLY WAY I CAN CRY
IS THROUGH MY MOUTH.
[howling]
[overlapping howling]
- I FORGOT TO HANG UP,
OLD FRIEND.
I'M SENDING OVER MY LAWYER
ZACK SWORD.
[sword unsheathes]
- I'VE NEVER LOST A CASE.